hello grammarians we've talked a little
about the difference between these
special adjectives
a and an and the also known as
the articles i want to go a little
deeper
now we know that v is the definite
article
and a or an is the indefinite
right if you're being non-specific in
language you'd use an indefinite article
as in may i have an orange if you want
to talk about one orange in particular
you'd use the definite
article may i have the orange now into
this framework i'd like to introduce a
complication
into that indefinite article something
to chew on
something to think about you'll notice i
said the indefinite article is a
or an what's with that or
when do we use a and when do we use an
and the answer to that question comes
down to one thing
and one thing only the next sound to
come
out of your mouth let us take for
example
two apes the orangutan and the bonobo
orangutan starts with o bonobo starts
with
b marvelous great apes cousins to humans
treat them with love and respect
when you say a word that begins with a
consonant which is to say
any sound that you make when your lips
or your teeth or your tongue
are touching you say a
a bonobo the b
sound requires my lips to come together
and then pop apart
when you say a word that begins with a
vowel sound which is any sound that you
make with an open mouth and no
teeth lips tonguey business you say an
an orangutan orangutan starts with
an o sound
little vocal warm up so you can see how
this is going to break down
right whatever sound comes after the
indefinite article
is going to determine the shape the
indefinite article
takes a pencil
and open door a zebra
an extra pudding cup a sailboat
an nba player a unicorn
wait well hold up
do you notice something weird about
those last two examples nba
player well that begins with n doesn't
it and unicorn begins with you
so why isn't it a nba player and
and unicorn because and this is the
crucial
complicated confusing part it's not
about the letter
that the word begins with in spelling
it's about the sound
that letter makes so nba doesn't begin
with the nuh
sound it's not na ba it's
n ba and unicorn
doesn't begin with an uh or an oo sound
it begins with
ya you unicorn
it's not about the letter it's about the
sound
e in nba is a vowel sound so it's
an nba player and
ya in unicorn is a consonant sound
notice how you lift your tongue
as you practice the difference between
unicorn
and unicorn
so it's a consonant sound it's a unicorn
same deal with words that begin with
silent h
like herb or heirloom
or hour an hour had passed
ow i'm going to start an herb garden
er that cuckoo clock is an
heirloom air why does this happen
what's the difference between a and an
the nuh
sound in and helps separate sounds here
listen to this
incorrect example for my snack today i
ate
a apple sounds weird right one right
after the other
ah now listen to this for my snack today
i ate
an apple the nuh in an
is kind of like a springboard from one
vowel sound
into the next ah napol
and that's what i want you to take away
from this lesson because it can be very
confusing and well
indefinite but think about the sound
that the word makes not the letter that
it begins with
an orangutan a bonobo and
nba player a unicorn a
you can learn anything dave it out